j'accueille matin bruno gaccio et
philippe bilger
bonsoir
bonsoir dont bruno gaccio tout le monde
le connaît c'est le patron des guignols
philippe bilger vous êtes un petit peu
moins connus bien train vous êtes avocat
général alors c'est quoi un avocat
général un avocat général c'est un kipré
en ce qui me concerne c'est aussi une
fonction puisque depuis 8 ans 9 ans je
suis avocat général à la cour d'assises
de paris
n'ayez pas peur et les passions du tout
alors non et non avec lui alors vous
avez été contacté tous les deux par la
production de vis ma vie pour échanger
vos vies 1 comment ça se passait super
bien
oui tu es devenu avocat général oui
c'est absolument fabuleux d'être
accusateur public
ouais et en plus j'ai appris ça avec
philippe bilger c'est que ça implique
une responsabilité terrible parce que
quand on est accusateur public on a un
rôle extrêmement important dans un
tribunal parce que on a les faits on a
un crime généralement devant soi et on
est obligé de déterminer la vraie peine
la peine extrêmement justes avait
d'accord s'étaient fixés les verts
actuellement mais on peut même requérir
des vagues équipements lorsqu'on estime
que l'accusé est innocente femme est
déjà arrivé vous avez demandé perpétuité
déjà bel et bien sûr bien sûr mais je le
dis sans aucune volupté prenez moi je
voudrais pas mêler la tragédie
judiciaire au divertissement même
intelligents savent avoir fui dans le
bouquin vous avez fait un livre tous les
deux qui s'appelle le guignol et le
magistrat sur la liberté d'expression
vous le décrivez comme gauchistes
anarchisant anti-américain anti
religieux anti puces anti tout fumant
fait tout l'intérêt du dialogue parce
que fit le dialogue avait été facile il
aurait été satisfaisant que je
l'entretiennent avec moi même et il me
semble que c'est peut-être le grand
mérite du livre s'est créé un dialogue
sans complaisance violent qui peut nous
renvoyer l'un et l'eau dans des camps
très opposées mais où on a tenté
d'appliquer les règles de la liberté
d'expression et toi tu le décris comme
juré akato élitiste et culturels moi je
c'est vrai c'est vrai absolument bien
alors tout commence au bar des sports à
issy les moulineaux
devant une mauresque un soir ça va pas
du tout alors le pitch le pile c'est la
liberté d'expression et ces limites
alors plus at-elle perdu ou gagné du
terrain ces dernières années voilà c'est
le sait le thème du bouquin c'est un peu
ça oui mais depuis octobre il s'en est
passé quand même quelques unes de
sympathiques notamment dassault qui a
acheté un tas de bouquins de journaux en
france et qui dit très clairement que
ben il a instillé dans ses livres
quelques idées saines les siennes j'ai
un peu les jetons ombre pour les
journalistes du figaro notamment
il ya une espèce d'inquiétude chez moi
qui existait avant parce que murdoch et
turner où on sur un milliard d'individus
la possibilité de leur laver le cerveau
un peu ce que fait le lait en france
je trouve que la liberté d'expression
elle n'a jamais été aussi apparente on a
l'impression qu'on peut tout dire mais
jamais dans ce flot de paroles des
choses intéressantes qui ont été dites
il ya de moins en moins que de pluralité
fils et vous vous reprochez aux guignols
leur manque de tendresse leur manque de
pitcher vous parler d'une sorte
d'aigreur qui les pousse à une
surenchère haineuse
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que le
rire n'est plus celui du faible à
l'encontre du puissant qu'un gène d'en
rire c'est qu'il est institutionnalisée
ancrée il est devenu une puissance qu on
off lui conteste moi je crois pas du
tout non parce que d'abord les émissions
d'humour comme les guignols ou celle de
thierry sont pas des émissions qui font
forcément le plus d'audience parce que
l'humour engagé n'est pas un humour
fédérateur des que dès qu'on se
positionne sur sûr je sais pas moi sur
une certaine idéologie qu'elle soit de
gauche ou de droite d'ailleurs on
segmente une partie du public
donc on à partir de là on peut pas dire
qu'on conçoit une puissance attend rêve
passe car attend ce sujet ce qui dit à
ton sujet bilger il dit ruquier vit en
permanence car il n'est pas sûr qu'il va
faire rire
l'élu sa mère mais c'est vrai j'ai
raison il a raison mais moi je préfère
rire de moi-même parce que je suis pas
tant que fils marc lui
mais mais vous avez tort
vous avez tort parce que je vous assure
jamais ce sont des rares fois où j'ai
regardé votre émission il y a des gens
qui m'ont fait rire et vous même en
particulier simplement ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'on n'impose l'étiquette rire
sur des personnes qui n'ont pas ce
talent gfr ça va s'arrêter au bout
et puis alors pareil pour baffie ça veut
dire que vous dites que ma fille en
rajoute une couche fou du roi avec une
couche de méchanceté et de sexe oui de
manière artificielle devant un public
robotisée ridiculiser que dira-t-on mais
je le il savait comme ils me font
plaisir
alors tout ça nous amène naturellement à
parler de tout le monde en parle on va
régler le problème tout de suite puis
après on verra ce que vous dites dans
votre bouquin alors c'est vous philippe
vous dites quand thierry ardisson
demande à michel rocard
si sucer c'est tromper fait-il bon usage
de sa liberté d'expression
alors je suis désolé de vous le dire
vous êtes avocat général vous envoyer
des gens en prison à perpète
donc il vaut mieux vous renseigner avant
parce que présentée comme ça bien sûr
que c'est ridicule de voir michel rocard
et lui dire est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper c'est vrai comme ça c'est à mon
avis un abus de la liberté d'expression
vous auriez raison
le problème c'est qu'il faut savoir
qu'avant ça on s'était tapé 25 minutes
d'interview de michel rocard sur le ps
eu sur la csg etc
et après il ya une petite interview
formaté qui est un jeu qui s'appelle à
l'arthrose
est-ce que voilà est-ce que tu sais
c'est tromper mais ramener cette
interview de 25 minutes à ça franchement
est ce pas là qu'ils savent on semble
pas c'est pas la question qui me choque
c'est y répondre
ah ouais vous voyez moi je trouve tout à
fait normal que vous pouviez toutes les
questions d'ailleurs qui fraîche pour
vous les vins interdire mais je n'y
répondrai pas vous savez vous quand même
savoir que michel rocard il s'est marié
trois fois arrivé derrière moi qui s'est
mariée je vais avoir 70 ans
si l'américain qui aime les femmes et
qui n'est pas surpris par cette question
mais on peut les aimer sans être obligé
de répondants ses conditions à une
question qui relève un petit peu de
l'intimé oui vous en conviendrez
convient autant avec l'a1
c'est fait pas prendre collard alors
vous parlez également aussi d'une
interview de airy routier qui a fait un
livre sur bernard arnault le patron de
lvmh et vous dites dans le bouquin avec
gaccio que cette interview a été
enregistré une première semaine non
diffusés et re enregistré la semaine
d'après vous dites parce qu'il ya eu des
pressions des avocats d'arnaud pas du
tout pas du tout il ya eu simplement des
remarques du service juridique de france
2 où moi je donnais l'impression
d'endosser les propos des routiers donc
ça devenait répréhensible et la semaine
d'après ben on l'a fait sans que
j'endosse les propos de herri routier
simplement ce que vous oubliez de
remarquer quand même c'est que c'est la
seule émission on a reçu et les routiers
quand même un surnom mais j'ajoute les
autres ils ont eu peur de bernard
arnault jeu là vous donnez un démenti
qui me touche qui vous convaincre - oui
même si on s'est pris en deux fois mais
il arrive que vous invitiez des gens
bien ce qui me gêne c'est quand vous
faites venir des gens qui n'ont pas
brillé par quelque chose de positif je
pense un ancien chanteur que vous faites
venir uniquement parce que à deux
reprises il a été pris et condamné pour
conduite en état alcoolique
jean jacques debout oui non dans sa fiat
forme dit non si vous voulez ce qui me
gêne c'est un petit peu alors avec votre
votre aura médiatique
la prime que vous donnez à des vêpres et
à des comportements qui peut être fière
était remarquable moi je l'aimais bien
anti chantait il ya 20 ans mais qui
aujourd'hui n'apporte rigoureusement
rien vous voyez ya tant de gens qui
viendront jamais chez vous et qui font
remarquable
les raisons et chantal goya alors on
arrive à thierry meyssan voilà que ce
serait la dernière parce qu'on a pas
parlé que de tout le monde en parle en
mon mari par mais suivez moi thierry
meyssan bon vous en avez entendu
tellement parlé que vous en avez
peut-être assez non non moi je me suis
expliqué le langer j'ai dit que j'ai été
abusé par l'appartenance de thierry
meyssan réseau voltaire
c'est vrai qu'il avait beaucoup lutter
aussi contre le front national donc
c'est quelqu'un qui au départ je
trouvais plutôt crédible
bon j'ai pas pris assez de précautions
oratoires camp quand je les ai invités
ici effectivement comme vous dites je
m'en suis expliquée mais vous dites
aussi dans votre bouquin que ce qu'a dit
thierry meyssan dans cette émission ne
tombent pas sous le coup de la loi non
non non bien sûr toutes les absurdités
heureusement vous font pas pénalement
répréhensible oui oui non et puis c'est
vrai quand même des choses qui sont
inexpliqués dans cette affaire on a
quand même trouvé le passeport de
mohammed atta au sommet des ruines du
world trade center
quand on pense que le mec s'était
encastré dans l'immeuble avec son avion
c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus tard on
retrouve le passeport c'est des choses
que les journalistes français n'ont pas
cherché à expliquer une des choses les
plus intéressantes qui avait été dit ici
c'était quand quelqu'un dit qu'un avion
qu'aucun avion on est rentré dans le
pentagone le minimum quand on est
directeur du journal c'est d'envoyer
immédiatement quelqu'un pour vérifier
oui ce qui n'a jamais été fait c'est une
chose acquise était comme ça nous avait
dit que donc on admet voilà alors vous
ne parlez pas heureusement pour vous que
de tout le monde en parlait de laurent
ruquier vous parlez aussi dans un
chapitre qui s'appelle rire de tout de
la fameuse histoire d des crevettes le
sketch que bruno gaccio avait écrit pour
patrick timsit
vous revenez là dessus et la question
que vous posez c'est faut-il qu'on
allait la faute de goût en fait c'est ça
que vous irez au pénalisation du bon
goût du bon goût du mauvais goût est ce
que la loi peut dire le bon goût oui ça
c'est vachement intéressant parce qu'on
finirait donc tous en taule nous parce
qu'avec quand on fait deux cent
cinquante émission parents forcément on
est pas de bon goût à chaque minute et
l'histoire des crevettes c'est quoi cris
le sketch il a voulu raconter je le
répète je tombe sous le coup de la loi
donc je vais pas me gêner
on avait je ne sais pas c'était pas une
histoire de crevettes on n'imaginait
qu'un garagiste qu'un chirurgien pardon
agirait avec le même comportement qu'un
garagiste et donc il ya un type qui
venait chercher sa fille qui était
censé être opéré il n'allait pas prêtes
on a 4 2 sur emprunts de la terminer par
contre j'ai fini la facture et tout ça
on va changer les poumons
c'est pourquoi les plumes on est pas
parce que l épouvante oury est le fumet
du charbon de bois ou quoi aimez vous
avez pris ou les poumons il sur un
mongolien on les a pris et commence à un
mongolien pour laisser des mongoliens
c'est des prototypes
c'est vrai c'est fabriqué comme ça et
puis c'est comme les crevettes roses à
part la tête tout est bon et tout d'un
coup le sketch est passé pendant des
mois et des mois au théâtre des années
en cassette et puis un jour il est passé
sur france 2
et puis il ya un parent de mongoliens
qui a trouvé ce propos absolument
horrible ce qui est je le comprends
parce que évidemment quand on comprend
ça et donc il ya eu procès et puis là on
est parti dans une sorte de délire que
timsit quand ils allaient quand il est
allé au tribunal il y avait des
pancartes dehors à boeing field avec des
mongoliens et tous étaient ils aider des
associations qui sont venus et patrick a
eu un peu peur et je le comprends parce
qu'en fait qui joue sa carrière aussi
c'est un peu compliqué pour lui moi je
suis derrière j'ai écrit la connerie bon
moi je rentrerai chez moi ça me pose pas
de problème lui par contre il est devant
chez son image c 'est c'est ce qu'il est
et donc il a préféré dire on arrête là
on s'embrasse on fait une assoc il a une
parole qui était très belle au tribunal
l'a dit si vous pensez qu'en me
condamnant vous allez trouver le mal
absolu et que je suis le représentant de
ce mal absolu contre le malheur de ses
enfants alors condamné moi ça vaut la
peine si vous pensez que c'est juste une
connerie que j'ai dérapé vaut mieux
s'arrêter tout de suite parce que ça n'a
aucun sens si un jour fait une blague
sur les canaux dactylo vous allez avoir
le syndicat décennaux dactylo qu'il ya
non pas de blagues sur les sélects non
les corses les homos les femmes les et
ainsi de suite
alors ça va jusqu'à des cas plus graves
comme effectivement les les trisomiques
mais voilà ça veut dire qu'il faut quand
même faire attention et que le débat
aurait été alors nommé ajoute moi juste
une chose c'est que la blessure
elle peut être à mon avis que dans la
récurrence c'est à dire si un comique
passer son temps à se moquer des
handicapés et vieux temps à problèmes
par contre la vanne qui sort comme ça ou
qu'on lâche comme ça dans un contexte
donné dans un sketch donnée qui n'est
pas un sketch sur les trisomiques là
pour le coup qui a un sketch sur autre
chose je vois pas on va rester dans la
faute de goût si on ne peut pas
condamner la faute de goût pourquoi tout
le monde a fait chier ce pauvre patrick
sébastien avec avec casser du noir à ce
moment là
c'est pas tellement qu'ils fassent ce
sketch casser du noir c'était pas ça qui
nous gêne c'est qu'il avait ramené le
pen et qui riait avec et on se disait
non au nom fait pas ça bordel et lui au
lieu de se dire bon vous avez raison les
mecs j'ai fait le con il s'est mis dans
un oui c'est les intellos qui m'attaque
je suis le pauvre rugbyman
tout le monde m'en veut il sait il
s'enfermer dans cet essai routier reese
c'est boukari et nous on est on n'était
pas là dessus on était juste sur david
pas le pen les connais mange pas avec et
dieudonné alain gelly comment pensez
vous que justice les traitaient moi je
je trouve fille si je suis bien
l'histoire judiciaire de dieudonné il a
été relaxé deux foires je crois et eut
condamné une troisième fois je trouve
que c'est discutable c'est peut-être
répréhensibles des gens ont pu être
choquées mais je trouve que dans une
société qui veut être une société de
liberté il me semble que là pour une
fois la jurisprudence a été avivée en le
relaxant et en plus lorsque je vois les
tentatives qui ont été faites à fond
l'encontre après je trouve que c'est
scandaient lé fait d'accord avec ça 3
n'ai rien à ajouter ceux qui parlent
bien il parle bien c'est un vrai plaisir
disant qu'il avait enfin quoi ouais je
ne penserai pas dîné tous les soirs avec
mes mecs c'est un mec bien les gosiers
le bouquin vous faisiez c'est à table a
commencé à table et fillon avant dé bain
on a fini par écrit parce qu'on se parle
et plus on a on a préféré arrêter la
table parce que fanon non parce qu'en
plus dans mes il picole ils sont
nombreux
ces répliques vous dites ça rejoint la
sphère dieudonné aujourd'hui il est
impossible de critiquer la politique
israélienne sans être taxé
d'antisémitisme et vous appelez ça non
plus de la liberté d'expression de la
timidité d'expression oui je dirais que
ça n'est peut-être pas aussi fif
thématiques que je le dis mais parce
qu'il est évident que certains font
passer un antisémitisme derrière une
apparente crédit politique juin
conscient mais tout même
on va très vite dans l'accusation
d'antisémitisme
lorsque vous avez des esprits à
l'évidence moralement impeccable qui se
permettent de critiquer la politique
d'israël
ils ne sont absolument pas antisémite
moi je suis en train de réclamer en ce
moment une loi pour accusations
d'antisémitisme abusif
ouais parce que on peut pas continuer à
dire assimilé des gens aux nazis à des
exterminateurs
il faut il faudra un moment arrêter ça
on est contre la politique d'israël on a
droit d'être même de rire du rite juif
pourquoi j'aurais le droit de me moquer
du pape pourquoi se moquer des musulmans
sans que ça pose d'énormes problèmes
et pourquoi dès qu'on arrive sur le rite
juif avec les papillotes le truc là en
disant je trouve ça ridicule
ah non non antisémite un nom j'ai le
droit de rire de ce rite aussi il est
normal qu'on soit plus prudent quand on
se moque des rites religieux juif que
catholique ou musulman c'est que tout
simplement dans notre pays plus
récemment il ya quand même eu un
massacre antisémites alors que les
massacres catholiques ou musulmans dans
notre pays en tout cas sont beaucoup
plus anciens c'est quand même une des
raisons pour lesquelles on se doit
d'être un peu plus prudent en tout cas
la ligue nationale a dit adieu donné à
l'époque on lui on lui avait dit ça je
l'avais dit les juifs c'est pas les
belges ou les suisses quoi sert m on a
pas tués pendant la guerre des millions
de belges des millions de suisses sous
prétexte qu'ils étaient belges et je
vous suis bien sûr
seriez vous savez la crise et on peut
rire de tout mais pas avec n'importe qui
voilà ça c'est quand même la grande
leçon parce que vous parliez de tout à
coup il histoire de casser du loir je
regrette mais en effet à chaque chaque
situation en fait ce sont presque
toujours des cas très précis et s'il ya
une réaction comme ça épidermique de la
population et que les choses ne passent
pas c'est parce qu'elles ne doivent pas
passer et je crois que mel est une
réaction de la population willi
journalistes s'étaient tissés nous
bêtement on a tous sauté subitement nom
s'est exprimé ainsi mes 10 ans parce que
casser du noir ccc les alors la loi sur
l'homophobie à il en a parlé au début de
l'émission et de façon j'ai pas grand
chose à ajouter c'est vrai que quand une
loi permet comme le pacs c'est dire que
c'est un fait précis le pacs ont dit
vous avez le droit que vous soyez deux
hommes deux femmes un frère une soeur
même je crois que c'est possible
vous avez le droit si vous vivez
ensemble depuis très longtemps d'avoir
les mêmes droits
donc qu'une loi rendre le monde meilleur
rendent donne une espèce d'harmonie
c'est bien quand tout d'un coup cette
loi risque de nous empêcher d'en rire
d'une institution puisque si le mariage
devient une institution va se moquer du
mariage homo autant que d autres mariage
le jour on se moquera de son mariage et
la layan one n'avait pas le droit de
vous moquer de ce nul et attend avait
fait pas chier maintenant t'as pas le
droit
donc là la loi je sème un roman je
préférais qu'il y en ait pas et alors
sur la pédophilie vous dites des choses
très intéressantes vous dites on est
traités différemment lorsque l'année
andré gide ou gabriel matzneff ou robert
fut pied de lons le saunier un tiers
canin quel prix nobel de littérature et
l'autre qui prend 15 en quadri et je lui
pose de questions mais je lui pose les
faits son bouquin je lui dis est ce qu'à
un moment un jeune marocain qui se
tapent gide qui a 12 ans est-ce qu'il
sort grandi de cette expérience parce
qu'il aura côtoyé quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel est-ce que l'aspect
exceptionnel d'un être me rends à un
acte comme la pédophilie acceptable de
la question cegid qui doit se poser la
question de respecter à quelqu'un de
mineur jeunes et familles nomades
s devant la 17e chambre correctionnelle
si je l'avais eu ça n'aurait pas posé de
problème de requérir contre lui
est ce que la littérature excuse tout
c'est ça la question est en tout cas
c'est un cetain c'est un très grand
débat et il dure depuis depuis vingt
siècles
est ce que l'art excuse tout bon il faut
poser cette question l aigle au mali
dont le livre ça c'est juste pour voir
bilger en février c'est la mariant
frangy bizarre
m